wenn ihr wie ich auch dieses jahr
ziemlich nordbad dann verdient ihr auch
und beliebte süßigkeiten alle leute die
wieder einmal waren und heute testen wir
unbeliebte süßigkeiten und zwar diese
süßigkeiten für die man sich nie
entscheiden würde wenn man im supermarkt
süßigkeiten kauf ich stand letztes im
supermarkt und wollte wie immer mir ein
schönes schokolädchen oder eine tüte
gummibärchen natürlich die mit extra
viel gelatine
da ist mir ein gedanke gekommen wer
kauft diese süßigkeiten die man sich
selbst nicht auf irgendwer muss hier
kaufen sonst gäbe es sie ja nicht so
lange
logisch und dann kam die nächste frage
warum kaufen sich die leute diese
süßigkeiten ich meine es gibt so so
viele snacks und süßigkeiten warum
entscheidet man sich für die folgenden
produkte anmerkungen an dieser stelle
unbeliebter süßigkeiten bedeutet in dem
fall unbeliebt für mich und was meine
wahrnehmung gesagt wenn eins dieser
produkte was es gleich teste zu euren
absoluten liebling süßigkeiten gehört
dann ist es auch okay hier brauchen wir
das nicht 100 meine kommentare schreiben
aber ich esse am liebsten oder wisst ihr
was schreibt mir dass ich möchte echt
wissen ob es leute gibt die nicht dass
auch kaufen ich bin super macht gefahren
und habe mir erst mal diese epische nen
keks eingeholt der jemals in die schule
gegangen ist oder großeltern hatte
sollte diese scheinen ja wohl auch
kennen und da kann man halt süßigkeiten
reinmachen
das ist unsere bewertungs schale
wie kommen wir sie sich keinen rein ich
nicht mag und da kommen die guten rhein
ist gut das können wir so links und
rechts boom falls sie ihm ein arzt mehr
video nicht gesehen habt ich habe eines
mr video hochgeladen und auf dem i hier
oder dort könnt ihr meine nasa mehrkanal
abonnieren
da kommen auch bei videos also ich muss
hier das erst mal alles so den meisten
zum rollen
herr bringen und natürlich darf in einem
video wo ich unbeliebt die süßigkeiten
probiere eine unbeliebte so da nicht
fehlen
grace oder in amerika ist great also
weintraube ein riesenhit in deutschland
nicht wasser zucker traum saft
konzentrat konservierungsstoffe 232
sogar dies deutet auf die adventszeit
[Musik]
ungelogen es schmeckt einfach mit
zuckerwasser es ist zucker wasser wir
fangen mit einem klassiker kennt ihr
diese kekse schon gerne lehne sie ganz
viele verschiedene kekse wird da gab es
immer diese ein keks sorte die übrig
geblieben ist weil sie einfach keiner
mag es gibt typen indem man einfach
diese unbeliebten krieg zu kaufen kann
und jetzt was ich mich davon überzeugen
dass diese sorte eigentlich mega cool
ist wenn sie allein gegessen wird
hier würde ich essen dann würde ich
nichts anderes mehr im haus wert müssen
was ich meine
wie schmeckt eigentlich schlecht also
ich probiere das nicht denkt mir so aber
sie lernen
das könnte uns langweilig sein kommen
sie jetzt nicht auf dem roten teller
okay leute es wird noch so viel
verrückter als nächstes ich bringe jetzt
natürlich diese was ist das überhaupt
kurze zeit habe ich war mit meinen
eltern früher man so ein weihnachts
theaterstück von der firma von meinem
vater und danach gab es immer so eine
süßigkeiten tüte und es gab immer diese
spiegeleier von dom keine ahnung was es
ist auf jeden fall fand ich das jedes
mal so und ich würde mir niemals im
supermarkt das aussuchen
schreibt mir gern haben den supermarkt
geht und euch diese dinger holt also
sofort ist das letzte mal mit zehn
gegessen vielleicht ist es super lecker
und ich fand's einfach damals blöd
ist ja ein kurde mit natürlichem aroma
bisschen cherry das kleid noch richtig
rein aber das hier ist schmeckt wie so
eine zuckerglasur für kekse und
irgendwie auch nicht sehr viel rum
wer die sachen einfach an weihnachten
meiner familie bringt so kleine tüten
mache ich dann und dann verschenkt ich
das und dann fühlen sie sich so schuldig
dass sie das dann essen müssen guter
plan machen wir weiter
die bananen wo afrikanische libanon sind
band förmige schokoladige okay es
schmeckt nicht so schlecht wie das aber
was muss in meinem leben passiert sein
dass du dich für sie leben im supermarkt
entscheidest es überrascht mich nicht es
ist gelebt was nach banane schmeckt und
mit schokolade überzogen ist für schwere
entscheidung kinder so zwischen ich mag
es nicht und ich finde es nicht nötig
ist schon okay aber andererseits auch
nicht
es schmeckt nicht schlecht ok bitte
lieber gott gibt jetzt einfach etwas
gutes er kommt zwar muss disco zitronen
rührkuchen ich mag einen guten zitronen
rührkuchen versteht mich nicht falsch
aber schon mein leben lang stehe ich im
supermarkt und schaue mir dieses ding an
und denke mir wer kauft ist es hat eine
weiße zucker glasur und die lieblosen
streusel aller zeiten obendrauf es sind
halt einfach traurig aus
heute bietet sich also leute das ist
mein zitronen rührkuchen bon appetit
kommt heute sind zwei der wenigen
minuten verdient ich weise hätte mir ein
stück abschneiden können ich liebe den
geschmack meistens haben so fertigkuchen
so ein backpulver nachgeschmack absolut
geil
das spüre ich doch erst mit einer
trauben so darunter die brauchen
abwasser die flüsse ist auch ein
klassiker zur weihnachtszeit aber auch
das habe ich als kind glaube ich jetzt
mal gegessen weil ich das halt immer so
langweilig fand mehr speck ich nehme
alles zurück pfeffernüsse sind nicht
unbeliebt super beliebt also den
beliebtheits status wächst hier eine
politische leben komm rüber horizont
reise geht weiter erfrischungs stäbchen
erfrischungs stäbchen habe ich noch nie
gegessen und ich weiß nur dass ich habe
es mir mal angeschaut also zucker drin
und da habe ich gesehen ist auch
erfrischungs stäbchen von chupa chups
gibt und dann dachte ich mir so eine
erfrischung stäbchen so beliebt dass
selbst top klubs auf den zug aufspringt
und sagt hey wir damit auch eine sorte
mama mama kannst du mir bitte
erfrischungs stäbchen einlass die
ammoniten ich bin kein kinder
überraschen ich will erfrischungs
stäbchen l
ihr seid hier live in dem video seite
mal ordentlich hinlegen
warum helfen sie erfrischen bestätigt
philipp ich danach erfrischt aber es ist
so ein heißer winter erstmals
erfrischungs stäbchen
ich glaube das verträgt sich gerade
absolut nicht mit dem lebkuchen
geschmack im mund erfrischung stäbchen
und ich werden keine freunde sag ich
euch da weiß ich ja schon dass die mir
wahrscheinlich auch ganz fantastisch
schmecken werden auch hier wieder fabrik
ist erscheinungsbild ich sag mal so
attraktiv ist das nicht ja klar da und
ist eine erfrischung stäbchen
aufgebrochen und die ganze flüssigkeit
ausgelaufen und jetzt hat man hier eine
ordentliche abschluss stellt sich vor
man hat einen super-job lolli
geschmolzen und diese zuckrige
flüssigkeit einfach in schokolade
getunkt
wenn ihr frisch und stäbchen fans seid
schreibt man mit in die kommentare was
daran so lecker sein soll weil ich
verstehe es nicht
unser nächster ritter der tafelrunde
ziegler käfertaler klingt erstmal gut
waffen mit käse und kümmel kümmel mag
doch kaum jemand außer vielleicht ein
bisschen in ober 2 das ist es was man in
der kirche bekommt sei mit jesus und es
einen ziegler käfertaler machtkampf ohne
kümmel schmeckt das mega event zu
steinbach etwa jeden taler einfach so in
den körper herum weil die man auch super
da sehen kann sie mit über so kleine
schwarze körner den können so rauskommen
es ist gut zum snacken weil wenn zum
beispiel gerade germany's next topmodel
oder so cooks und dann deine käse thaler
ist dann kannst du nicht so schnell und
so viel davon essen weil du dich erst
mal darum kümmern muss dass der könig
draußen ist ja es ist auf jeden fall
besser als ich gedacht hätte dass ihn
kommt es auf tiefen werde ein ganz
beliebtes gewürz neben kümmel ist
natürlich anis plätzchen feines biscuit
gepäck
seltsam hätte ich mir niemals in meinem
leben ausgesucht und deswegen habe ich
gekauft also anis riecht nach lakritze
es lässt mich ganz josef fill hat um so
zu trinken oder lakritz zu essen
man wird sie auf jeden fall an den
geschmack positiv es gibt hunderte
sorten haribo
wer entscheidet sich dafür hände hoch
sie sehen wirklich aus wie brombeeren
nur mal sagen wir haben hier eine pinke
und eine schwarze ding zuerst nein für
diese außen dinge ganz geil aber dieses
ziel in der mitte das ist wahrscheinlich
auch leute die diesen gillet aufschnitt
essen bisschen was ich meine dieser
aufschnitt wie man so 1 1 drin sieht und
champignons und fleisch auf hinweise aus
dem heli somit eine weihnachtsfeier was
wird alles noch weggegessen keine sorge
flamme in madeira da wird jetzt gespannt
ich auch schokolade gefüllt mit rum edel
marzipan und flamme in madeira
vorzubereiten
ich wusste nicht was man da man die
batterie mandela die hier ramadan
das kann schon chinesen amadea weil die
ersten weine in la mama warum wir nicht
bestimmt gut schlafen das riecht so
deine alkohol führen könnt wann kommt
man in dieses alter wo man sagt
mordserie lecker blaume in madeira
lecker
schokolade mit 90 prozent kakao lecker
das ist unser endgegner heute schokolade
mit 90 prozentigen kakaoanteil ich habe
schon im letzten video gesagt dass dafür
der schokolade für leute über 30 ist da
habe ich viele antworten bekommen dass
ihr auch natürlich das gerne 130 aber
glaube es gibt niemanden auf dieser welt
der absichtlich und gerne 90 prozent
kakao ist wenn wir das jetzt jemand in
die kommentare schreibt sehr gerne 90
prozentigen kakao schokolade ist
[Musik]
gibt es irgendein rezept wofür war
90-prozentige schokolade braucht also
mit 90 prozent kakaoanteil normale
vollmilchschokolade hat so dreist dass
bitterschokolade hat so ab 50 60 70 aber
90 um eine happy abschluss zu kriegen
die sind wie erdnussflips nur aus mainz
und gesetzen und ohne geschmack ich geil
oder damit werde ich das im air video
aufnehmen um den bildungsauftrag hier an
dieser stelle zu erfüllen
kauft euch keinen scheiß es gibt viele
komische süßigkeiten auf der welt und
wir wissen nicht warum sie überhaupt
existieren ob sich die produktion bei
den verkaufszahlen überhaupt lohnt es
kann aber auch sein dass ich in meiner
blase liebe und glaube dass diese
süßigkeiten unbeliebt sind dabei sind
sie es gar nicht irren ist menschlich
sei man der stelle sich das video heute
gefahren gesehen waren mal wieder würfel
unbedingt das video ein solcher feinheit
und abonniert main kanal und local
aktivieren
manchmal neuen videos zu verfassen dann
schickt unbedingt manas mehrkanal aus
hier könnt ihr da mal raufgehen und
abonnieren
wenn damit die dicker geben